jamison taion
gonna toe the slab into boogie down
bronx on a thursday afternoon
man i would love to be out there michael
i love day games at yankee stadium
you can see on the year this will be his
14th start 18 walks 63 strikeouts 11
homers
next pitch swung online sharply to left
field that'll drop for a base hit so
the royals have their lead off man on to
start the ball game
and that breaking ball is in there and
whit with a delayed steal
swipes his 21st of the year wow
excellent pull off
with the delay you could tell sanchez we
saw sanchez
he stood up to throw the ball back to
the pitcher had to double clutch
that is a beautiful thing look at that
that's what it's designed for here's
ryan o'hearn
2-2 grounded into short right field
o'dore to voight and taion works out of
trouble
brad kellers trying to snap a string of
three consecutive starts allowing five
or more runs
he's better than that and he knows it he
just has to try less
just like his offense sometimes just try
a little bit less
let the ball reach its maturity when you
try less you don't overthrow
here's aaron judge
deep to right field o'hern back on the
track at the wall
see again hotter one nothing yanks
well in aaron judge's 70th game played
this year his 16th home run
[Applause]
so here is the left hand hitting rugi
odor
runners at first and third two out one
in one-nothing yanks
could be a tough play and it's a base
hit for outdoor
sanchez scores yankees lead two-nothing
merrifield playing in short right field
had a charge
and odor beat it out for an infield
single in a ribby
so first and second with one out and
judge comes up the payoff to judge
runners lead and the [ __ ] line to left
field airs on base head
wade goes to third and rounds it he's
coming home to throw his way off
line the throw to third not in time
dyson does not have much of an arm so
they ran weighed he
scored it's a bases and an rbi for
judge so the slumping judge has a homer
and a ribby single
and the yankees take a three-nothing
lead you know when you talk to aaron
judge he's always the same whether he's
going great or in a slump
and he's the one that keeps saying all
the time that it's every day and yet you
know you can't make it too
you can't get too high or too low i know
cliche that there's a reason things are
cliche and here comes cal eldridge
here's luke boyd that one is driven deep
to right field
or heard back track wall see ya
home run voight employees come off the
il
feeling it the yankees league four
nothing a line driving the right field
seats
oh he's cool hand luke as
he homers and the yankees take a four
nothing lead
well he didn't put the finger up but
probably wasn't sure he could have that
one was halfway up of the bleachers
it's a different sort of energy that
little boy brings not only to the lineup
but to the bench in the clubhouse
you gotta crack the two cans here right
[Music]
there the royals have their lead off man
on
for the third time four sebastian rivero
in the fifth
there's a shot down the left field line
and that is a fair ball
it'll roll into the corner and rivero
has his first major league hit
and he's going to knock in nikki lopez
who roars around third
to score so sebastian rivero has a big
smile on his face
and that baseball will be saved as
monster alberto
grabbed it and faked like he was
throwing it into the crowd
it's tyler wade with the bases loaded
two outs
and wade takes a called third strike
judge has a perfect day homered singled
and walked
lined into right center field a bullet
it's a base hit
it splits the outfielders and it goes to
the wall lemayo will be held at third
it's a double for judge he's come out
playing today
three for three with a walk well now the
infield has to come in
second and third nobody out gary sanchez
at the plate so it's not an enviable
position
for the royals to be in sanchez one for
three today yankees lead 4-1
looking for more
high drive left field going back dyson
still back
track a long three-run home run for
sanchez he keeps hammering away and it's
7-1 yanks eight home runs last
23 games and also a dramatic
change of the narrative tyonne's still
on the mound
his longest outing of the year was six
in the third on may 7th against
washington
strike three taylor down on strikes
[Music]
3-2 is high so lopez is on with a
one-out walk and that
will be all for tyonne there's dyson
first and second two outs
we're in the eighth 7-1 yanks
[Applause]
and he tips it into the glove of sanchez
three strikeouts
for cortez in the inning yankee stadium
the yanks have a 7-1 lead bottom of the
eighth
a run of its second one out here's
stanton
and sharply and through for base head
through the drawn in infield judge will
score it's an rbi single for stanton
his third hit of the day and it's 8-1
yanks
[Music]
well we talked about this part of the
yankee lineup a whole different
feel now judge sanchez stanton
and now voight and that brings up
gutierrez
who is in mirrorfield spot
and this should do it high fly ball
shallow center coming on
gardner slides and makes the play as a
yankees win
eight to one they lose a tough first
game of the series they battle back and
win the second game and they finally get
something that they haven't had a lot of
they get a laugher
and nail this one down by a score of
eight to one yeah off of last night as
you said a dramatic comeback
now they win this series and head on up
to boston feeling good about it
and that guy gary sanchez winning
this fan base back by the day by the
at-bat and rightly so